welcome to metaphysical milkshake i am
one of your hosts reza aslan i'm another
one of your hosts rayne wilson hey ray
you know i was thinking to myself the
other day uh you know i'm like already
planning on what am i gonna do with all
that like gobs and gobs of podcast money
that i'm soon going to make we're going
to be in the joe rogan territory pretty
soon reza absolutely i mean all we got
to do is just you know talk about how
the vaccine is isn't real and then the
money just comes pouring in
i'm thinking about it i don't know yet
have you thought about this what are you
gonna what are you gonna do with all
this podcast money
when i get my hundreds of millions of
joe rogan-esque podcast money coming in
from metaphysical milkshake the number
one podcast in the country
i have i have decided that i am going to
eliminate global poverty well that is a
very noble enterprise yeah it's pretty
simple i've boiled it down to a couple
of things there's seven billion people
in the world seven and a half billion
i'm going to buy everyone on the planet
their choice
either a jet ski
or a vitamix
i'm sorry
like a jet ski like the things that you
do on on like water
you know when you go to like jamaica you
can get jet ski rides you know and they
have
guys out there with like dreadlocks and
like rent a jet ski man i'm pretty sure
you can't eat a jet ski though right you
know you can make money from take
transporting people on jet skis you can
also make money opening a smoothie stand
with a vitamix
it's really pretty simple it's not as
complicated as we think ending global
poverty okay can we just get real and
you haven't thought about the fact that
if you're landlocked or if you don't
have electricity that neither of those
things just i just feel like i feel like
we'll work we'll work that solving
solving global poverty like bravo yes
that is a very okay
i'm thinking there might be better ways
than everyone gets a vitamix although i
have a vitamix and it's changed my life
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
oh do you have a better idea reza you've
got a better idea
i
truly truly i do not have a better idea
though i'm sure there's one out there
but i feel like this is one of those
times where maybe an actor is not the
person you want to ask
about how to solve global poverty
celebrities know a lot about what is
wrong with the world by no means am i am
i denigrating your your uh knowledge
of of the world by any means although
i'm thinking maybe there's a better way
than than skinny
and uh who do you suggest we speak to i
have the guy i have the guy for
christian slater
jennifer aniston it's tom cruise it's
tom cruise believe it or not not a
celebrity though kind of a celebrity i
guess a like a nerd celebrity jeffrey
jacks do you know jeffrey sachs i have
heard of dr jeffrey sachs he has uh
published many many books this is the if
we're going to ask this question
how do we end poverty
then we're going to ask jeffrey sachs
that question he has written hundreds of
academic articles and many books
including three new york times
bestsellers the end of poverty
commonwealth
and the price of civilization
reawakening american virtue and
prosperity but he's got a new book out
the ages of globalization geography
technology and institutions and uh by
the way you know he's got like 90 jobs
jeff sacks does he's a professor at
columbia he teaches at the center for
sustainable development there he's the
president of the united nations
sustainable development solution network
he's the guy who basically like uh did
the whole millennium uh global goals he
like advises
you know all these different countries
uh
he writes a book every couple of years
he's like bffs with bono uh
maybe if there's a guy who knows
how to end poverty i'm not saying your
ideas are bad but they're bad
it's jeff sacks he's also launched a
podcast called book club with jeffrey
sachs available now wherever you get
your podcasts so welcome to the show
help us in global poverty
jeff sacks
jeff sacks it's so good to see you
likewise i mean my friend jeff sacks as
i like to say i'm friends with a global
international economics doctor saxophone
can you be your friend too no i want to
be your friend too and i'm happy to be
reza's friend so here we go we'll share
him can i call you since uh dr sax is
kind of formal can i call you like jeffy
well jeff jeff would be just good yeah
only his wife sonia can call him jeffy
how about jeffy weffy well i went
through that phase but that was a a few
decades ago okay fine jeff it is okay
jeff so uh
jeffy before we get too deep into this
conversation let's just kind of start by
making sure that we understand
uh exactly the problem at hand here so
what exactly is
poverty like how would you define
poverty
and
and how would we measure it before we
start talking about what do we do about
it yeah poverty is
easy to define and understand it means
when you don't have the things that you
really need for a decent life and
it's a little shocking in our world
today which is a very rich world on
average that
some people don't have uh
safe water to drink some people don't
have
uh
80 cents to save them uh
from about a malaria because that's all
it costs some people don't have
any chance of going to school because
there's no school anywhere around
so these are extreme deprivations and
my
my thing is that it's just weird in the
21st century that we still have this of
course there was poverty all through
human history until we figured out how
to do a lot of things better than uh
than we knew with the start but at this
stage in the world it's just
a bit unforgivable
that
hundreds of millions of people
billion people 2 billion depending on
where you draw the line on deprivation
are suffering
extraordinary uh
losses and and uh inabilities to even
survive
and
this is kind of still treated as normal
in the world
so that that's uh what gets me uh that's
what uh also get gets me going each day
because i'm i'm trying to do something
to uh to stop that in your new book this
ages of globalization which is just
fantastic and we're we're not
specifically speaking you don't
poverty is definitely addressed in the
book throughout the book but uh you have
another book about the end of poverty
itself and poverty is the topic of
today's conversation but one of the
things you brought up in this book which
was fascinating was this idea of the
malthusian curse
can you tell us what that is
well you know there was an idea by a
person uh thomas robert malthus who
wrote in
1798 uh
actually quite a a religious uh guy but
a rather pessimistic
guy who said you know
we are doomed to poverty
uh
you look at all of human history people
have lived in poverty
and
he said there's a reason for that which
is that every time humanity has peaked
its head a little bit above poverty
more children have survived their
young age less child mortality we would
say technically
people have more children the population
rises
and what looked like a little bit of a
cornucopia that we'd have enough
suddenly there are more mouths to feed
and living standards are driven back
down to subsistence to mere survival so
malthus uh
posed a puzzle uh he said how could we
ever escape
from poverty if every time we make a
near escape
we just get population increase and that
drives us back down to subsistence and
being the pessimist that he was he said
we shouldn't even try
to help because it's what's the point
the unintended consequences are going to
overwhelm us there is a sense amongst
most
people in the world and i and look i'm
just speaking anecdotally here i don't
have any data um
i'm not an economist but i do think that
there is a sense that people tend to
think of poverty like it's some kind of
divinely mandated inevitability you know
like you you kind of mentioned it to
yourself like look we've always had uh
you know uh poverty we've always had uh
people who um
had to deal with you know the absolute
human indignity of not being able to
know where their next meal is going to
come from and so i think a lot of people
think well we've always had that we
always will so that's just the reality i
i think there there there really are two
uh questions here one is a kind of a
very practical uh empirical question
just a fact question uh what's happening
to
how many people live in poverty what's
happening to the poverty rate uh in uh
history uh and and seconds a
philosophical one that i want to come to
in a moment but one thing i can say
pretty surely is that the
the proportion of
humanity living in poverty has come down
dramatically in the last 200 years
and as best we can
see
uh 200 years ago at the time that
malthus wrote
his uh his treatise
80 to 90 percent of the world
uh
even that's conservative number maybe 90
to 95
we would say oh my god they're living at
the edge of survival that's subsistence
living and today
while one can discuss a lot about the
specifics it may be 10 to 20 percent of
humanity in other words there's been a
transformation uh
we have
poor people in all parts of the world
including in the united states to be
sure uh but the kind of poverty that we
have is a is a much lower burden on
humanity uh than in the past so it's not
as if
it's always the same generation in
generation out so that's at a very
important point
that affects a lot of my own thinking
because of course i've studied and
pondered that for decades and uh i know
that progress is possible but that comes
to a second
philosophical point also a religious
point which is
you can
almost divide religious thinkers into
the optimists and the pessimists uh and
uh
some religious thinkers say religion is
about the perfectability of uh humanity
and uh
we can do better and god is uh our
our our model our guide uh our idea of
what perfection is
and we should do better uh so we should
make the kingdom of uh heaven on earth
uh uh god's kingdom as a as a an earthly
possibility and then other uh
philosophers and and religious thinkers
throughout history basically said
we are so screwed
we're damned uh
original sin
human uh
mentality makes it impossible for us to
sustain anything sensible uh and don't
think about
uh the possibility of
sustained improvement and in this sense
i think malthus was not only making
very
actually very clever and insightful
technical arguments he was expressing a
certain variant of philosophical thought
but putting it into even mathematical
terms i would say was explaining why
pessimism was the right way to go i'm an
optimist
not an unconditional optimist but i
believe
that progress is possible that it's not
vanity that we're not doomed by original
sin or uh even by
our semi-craziness which is undoubted uh
but actually we could figure out how to
do certain things and one of the things
i think we could figure out is how to
end poverty but there is definitely
you know an undercurrent of
uh of of uh
philosophical optimism in that view and
i have
my share of
critics i think maybe they are the
predominant side say are you crazy we
can't end poverty
listen proper hydration and vitamins can
help support a strong immune system
because flu season is right around the
corner okay so true making hydration a
priority helps us feel healthier on a
day-to-day basis and fuels us to be at
our highest potential are you trying to
say that one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone because
that's a true statement it's got as much
potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
it's got no artificial flavors no
preservatives it's got less sugar than
an apple liquid iv is on a mission to
change the world their company is
donating 4 million servings in response
to covid19 products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military liquid iv
has donated over 11 million servings
globally so grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use your code
milkshake at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code
milkshake at liquidive.com
folks if you're carrying a credit
balance month after month it can feel
like you're in a never-ending cycle of
debt
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead upstart is
a fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan
all online so you can pay off your
credit cards consolidate high interest
debt
you can fund personal expenses over half
a million people have used upstart to
get one fixed monthly payment upstart
knows you're more than just your credit
score and it's expanding access to
affordable credit and unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute online rate check you can see
your rate up front for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars or as
rain calls it couch change
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com milkshake that's upstart.com
milkshake don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application so
once again where you gonna go
upstart.com
milkshake
your thesis of the end of poverty and
when when did you write that book it was
two years in 2005. you had this thesis
which was pretty revolutionary at the
time it's like hey guys hey kids let's
end poverty yeah this is this is
actually handable it's always the kids
are doing it everybody's doing it you
wrote about how it could be ended in
2025. obviously it hasn't been but um
looking at that prediction in our
current world
you know we've had this pandemic you
know it's a different somewhat different
political situation
now than it was uh 15 years ago um do
you think that prediction is still
correct how would you adjust it now
looking back on the on a 15-year view of
your of your of your goal yeah let me
tell you one interesting fact which is
that in 2020
china uh
even though sometimes we're not allowed
to say anything nice about china but i
do because i i
i
have visited china for 41 years now 40
years now
and
i've watched they
ended poverty last year they ended
extreme poverty wow that and that was a
remarkable uh a
an absolutely remarkable achievement for
a civilization basically because it's
1.4 billion people almost 20 percent
of humanity and back in the 1980s and
1990s depending again on exactly the
measurements one uses poverty was
80 percent of the chinese population
maybe 70 percent i started interrupting
i remember being a kid of like it was
literally like eat all your food on your
plate remember the starving kids in
china kids in china or the starving kids
in korea if someone had said 30 or 40
years ago china's gonna end poverty and
it's going to do it in the year 2020 it
would look as fanciful
as you know maybe this idea that we
could end poverty uh
worldwide consider the following
we have in the world by the the latest
count which is kept by
forbes magazine
they publish an issue
uh once a year the billionaires issue
i'm a definitely a billionaire's lawyer
i i want to know who's on the list how
many and so on they're
2755 billionaires on the list
this year
their combined
net worth their combined wealth of these
2
700 people
13.1 trillion dollars
whoa what 13.1
trillion
dollars so
think of it uh 1
of that
13.1 trillion so 10 is 1.3 trillion uh
and uh 10 of that is 130 billion so one
percent of their net worth is 130
billion dollars
that's basically what you need to get
every kid in school in the world to have
health care for everybody to have safe
water sanitation i feel like this is a
this is an ancient argument like tax a
rich and you know thomas piketty wrote
about it in capital and karl marx
certainly talked about it and like oh
and poverty tax the rich if only the
billionaires would give up half of their
billions or whatever but isn't it a
little more complicated than that what
do poor people need now
to get out of poverty
not a lot they need electricity
they need connectivity and a device so
that they can listen to your show
because what are they going to do
otherwise
we are huge in sub-saharan africa we
need the poor to listen to metaphysical
milkshake and to buy from our sponsors
there you go and then they need
schools
right and they need clinics and
community health workers
and i spend uh you know i make my living
adding up how much all of that costs and
it's it's not a lot it's just more
than poor people can afford on their own
but but isn't this i'm sorry
you're the expert but i've i've been
working in haiti for the last 11 years
with my wife and been down there a
couple dozen times and and i think that
and i have i have witnessed extreme
poverty yeah and by the way you see it
there that's for sure i
will never forget the day i saw a woman
try to uh give us her baby
um and this wasn't because she loved her
baby the baby was sick and she knew she
couldn't take care of it and she knew
that a bunch of white people would
probably be in a better position to take
care of it and
and it was because she loved the baby
that she was trying to give it away and
um but i have never experienced anything
so heartbreaking
in my life but if you were going to try
and eradicate poverty in haiti and you
talk about electricity connectivity
clinics schools um some of these basic
things it that's it seems to me very
much easier said than done because you
have a government that is so corrupt and
so ineffectual
let me tell you a couple stories about
haiti in in my experience
uh one one is uh with uh aristide uh
president aristide said to me
in uh early 2001
uh
thereafter me jeff uh meaning
the gringos uh meaning us in the united
states it was the bush administration
uh and uh
he said you gotta help because they're
freezing
they're freezing
any uh
finance from the world bank the
inter-american development bank and
the imf
and
i i said oh you know
i'll i'll help you on that went back to
washington uh and sure enough
they were just starting they had the
idea look this guy's a leftist we're
gonna get rid of him
and then one day
uh an unmarked
plane came
and the american ambassador
went to uh aristide's house
and said mr president uh they're gonna
kill you unless you get on the plane
right now
uh and uh in this unmarked plane an
unmarked plane means a cia plane
uh they put him on and
18 hours later he
landed in the middle of africa in other
words the cia launched a coup against
aristide okay then fast forward
president pravall asked me for help
i first came the hurricane
which wiped out
so much of haiti then came the
earthquake in 2010
so
oh my god so i you know went uh back and
forth
and
there was no help uh i could go into a
long sad litany uh of uh how miserable
our government was and how completely
ineffectual
uh the so-called international community
which is not much of a community was and
then came cholera which was brought
inadvertently by un peacekeeping troops
so they had a cholera epidemic on top of
all of this
you know the truth of the matter is no
one gives a damn about haiti uh in the
world and
we installed dictator after dictator
by the united states from the united
states whether it was papadoc or baby
doc we we every time
anywhere by the way in the americas
there has been a progressive leader
for decades we said well we better get
rid of that guy because that's a
dangerous to united fruit or somewhere
else so there is so little attempt to
roll up our sleeves and say let's do
something
for
fellow human beings to actually solve
this problem okay so there you go bingo
you this is exactly the point jeff
because
you're right no one gives a damn about
haiti uh and you're absolutely right i
mean by the way when haiti became
independent
we did not recognize haiti for the first
60 years in the united states because we
were the most racist white supremacists
that's right country and it was
precisely
you're gonna have a black country ruling
itself in the neighborhood of the united
states hell no even more than that that
it was the first successful slave revolt
exactly ever and so we still had slaves
we were like no no we're not supporting
a slave revolt uh independence but this
is this is the point that i wanted to
make so
it's very clear
by almost every measurable term that we
have enough uh on the planet to make
sure that people aren't dying of poverty
you make this argument both in
in your work your your lectures and in
the end of poverty that essentially all
it really takes is about less than one
percent of uh the income of the rich
world and nobody ever has to die of
poverty ever again on the planet that's
as little as it takes which then begs
the question well what the [ __ ] then
like what i mean obviously yes there are
vested interests like you said political
and economic interests that are involved
in not doing anything about it what are
we doing
and
how hard it is
to get any attention i'll give you an
example by the way that's quite
interesting for me recently the united
states has given a loan of course and
nobody knows and it's fine uh we gave a
loan to uh
a
consortium
to put up digital connectivity in
ethiopia and it's a u.s government loan
of the several hundred million dollars
good okay now why did we do it
and it's interesting if i had ever gone
to say we should lend ethiopia several
hundred million dollars for digital
connectivity they said are you out of
your mind sacks are you completely crazy
why would we ever do that america first
and uh and on and on so why did we do it
because the chinese were the competitors
for this speculation so suddenly because
what america gets is
if we're if we need to do something to
stay number one in the world we'll do it
if it's only for poor people don't be
such a stupid sucker
i love this we should turn it into a
competition and then we'll do something
about it no but that's that's exactly it
seems you know as long as we say oh if
we don't do it china will do it yeah
maybe something will get done but the
idea that
hey and we should do it because uh
it's the right thing to do when we
barely notice it wouldn't really cost us
anything but let's get down to that i i
heard an amazing ted talk once i heard
it live i'm sure it's online somewhere
this guy had this great example there
was about eight years ago there was a
little girl who was hit by a motorcycle
in china and she was lying on the street
bleeding to death and they had video
from a security video and people were
walking around her and driving around
her and not paying her any attention and
he showed the video and he talked about
the outrage and the international
outrage over this incident
and then he brought up very cannily like
aren't we doing the same thing about
poverty aren't we doing the same thing
about a billion people that are going to
bed hungry every night isn't that the
same as a species we're walking around
the girl lying bleeding on the sidewalk
totally why is it so difficult for us as
a species to kind of
to to dig into to feel a connection to
and to take active steps in is there
something in our
in our wiring is it is it is it a
cultural thing well in fact that story
that you were telling reign about you
know being handed a baby in haiti it it
made my chest tighten just hearing you
tell that story made me want to run away
and
i mean obviously like i'm not a
heartless person you know i i care about
the world and about people and and i try
to do good and and i and i want to i
have you know every desire to to uh you
know help people who are in suffering
but i i'll be perfectly honest that when
i'm confronted with that level of
suffering and that level of poverty
i shut off i want to look away i can't i
don't want to i don't it's like a trauma
response and i think that's a that's a
that's a human thing i think honestly if
i were to say why don't we do something
about it yes vested interests are
involved politics are involved but i do
think that there is something about the
human condition that makes us
sort of turn away and flee from
uh this level of poverty even though we
can we can do something about it
this episode ladies and gentlemen is
brought to you by four sigmatic a
wellness company that is well known for
its delicious mushroom coffee mushroom
coffee oh i don't want mushrooms in my
coffee rain reza that's not how it works
no i'm just messing around of course it
doesn't taste like mushrooms it's
fantastic i've been starting my day with
four sigmatics ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane instead of just like
the normal regular coffee absolutely
feeling uptick in my productivity every
time i drink it it helps me when i'm
writing so we've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling mushroom coffee but this is
just
for metaphysical milkshake listeners get
up to 40 off plus free shipping on
mushroom coffee bundles to claim this
deal here's what you're going to do reza
tell them okay you're going to go to
4sigmatic.com
milkshake now remember this is an offer
that's only available for metaphysical
milkshake listeners it's not available
on their regular website so you want to
go to four sigmatic
that's f o u r s i g m a t i c dot com
slash milkshake and you'll save up to 40
and you're gonna get free shipping so go
right now to f o u r s i g m a t i c
four sigmatic dot com slash milkshake
and fuel your productivity and
creativity with some delicious mushroom
coffee and if there's anyone from the
four sigmatic company listening to this
i'm out of coffee so if you could just
please send me some more that'd be great
hey folks when it comes to saving time
and working more efficiently it's the
little things that start adding up and
hogging time in your day
grammarly premium gives real-time
suggestions on your writing so you can
get to the next item on your list in
record time it can give you clarity
suggestions so in other words it can
help you get your message across quickly
without you know repeating or using
unnecessary words it can give you vocab
suggestions so no more searching for
synonyms grammarly premium offers
suggestions to replace overused words
and phrases if you get the free version
of grammarly you're at the very least
say from the most embarrassing basic
spelling grammar and punctuation
mistakes the kind of mistakes that makes
me as a teacher just bang my head
against my desk
and
if you get grammarly premium
well that has advanced time-saving
features and it'll help you write more
clearly and efficiently hit send with
confidence and get your point across
more effectively with grammarly premium
get 20 off grammarly premium by signing
up at grammarly.com
milkshake that's twenty percent off at
grammarly g r a m m a r l y dot com
slash what is it milkshake
milkshake
[Music]
for for about seven years every time i
open my mouth the word bed net came out
because i was on a campaign to
get bed nets for people living in
malaria zones
finally it happened the breakthrough
came in 2007 they gave a billion bed
nets away malaria came way down
and so i went back to the u.s government
and i said look it works and malaria
deaths are way down all we need is
another three billion dollars it's one
and a half days of pentagon spending you
know
just let's get this done
so no no no we can't do that you know we
have a tight budget uh that was during
the obama administration by the way so
i i don't have an answer to this
question i i i think
maybe the fact that we really can end
poverty is
sufficiently new
in human history because it wasn't true
before uh maybe it's sufficiently new in
human history it just seems so damn
stupid and naive to say it could be done
and so it hasn't been internalized
but you know my my view is
i don't know whether we're gonna get to
it or not because we make a lot of
mistakes as as human beings uh we do a
lot of terrible things and and uh i'm
not you know intrinsically i i'm an
optimist in what we can do i'm not an
optimist necessarily that we will do it
but
these arguments are actually correct
so that uh
they're just they're numerical they're
demonstrable
but
they hit a wall
of
skepticism
of our politics
of all the things that
make our you know look at our country
how much more we could be doing but we
can't do anything because we're at each
other's throats it is a puzzle about
human human nature and human
understanding
but
to my mind it is not
a set of technical arguments at least
for me i've kind of gone through them
upside down right side up for decades
and i just can't see the technical uh
flaws yeah it's math it's math and it's
it's solvable
it's just we have to get
yes we have to you know cut through some
of the vested interests that keep us
from doing it like you rightly said um
but but i do think that we have to kind
of break through
the
the the psyche of uh you know those of
us who live in in the wealthy world when
you have the personal experience of
being in places that need a bit of help
the mystery of this disappears actually
uh and
the thing that i've
really felt
pretty deeply in my life
for
decades
and it wasn't
to be taken
you know as a self-evident truth
everywhere i've been
i have felt at home
uh with people you know whatever village
whatever religion whatever race uh
things that are supposed to be so
incredibly consequential
completely different cultures
race religion
at the core
it's so easy to make friends and to
see the the common
humanity
to make jokes to have a good time uh to
enjoy each other's company
and
i think that personal experience
definitely affected me a lot uh because
it made
the
it made the emotional hurdle no hurdle
at all you know it all came
down for me to
this basic arithmetic and what to do
with the technical arguments because
there's i don't feel any of the
emotional uh hurdle that well they're so
different or
why would we help them or
it's their own fault i don't feel any of
that uh
sense and maybe it's because of the just
the good luck of of the personal
engagement so you know i hope that
people could have
more of that direct
feeling and more of that direct
experience i think it makes a big
difference i i think you're right on
that i think you know my wife and i have
a
non-profit in haiti that
educates young women and girls and it's
simply we're teaching girls to read and
it's not rocket science like
just teach hundreds or thousands or tens
of thousands of of girls to read and you
will make the make it better and it's
whatever difference it makes rain and
it's pretty cheap and it's pretty easy
to do actually that is the number one
investment of all because if we can get
kids healthy enough to get them to learn
they'll figure out the rest right they
really will so that is absolutely the
most empowering single thing to do now
in the ages of globalization you talk us
through all of the different ages of
humanity in the industrial age etc the
there was the ocean age now we're moving
forward and
and we're here in the digital age and
you talk about that that history has an
arrow and it is moving towards an end
and there there seems to be kind of like
a
you know a chart of kind of
progress and difficulty moving forward
where's that arrow headed where are we
going
if you ask yourself what is
what is economic bliss
okay that i think is where we're going
now for me if you ask where is what is
economic bliss
it is sitting
pretty much all day
at a coffee shop in piazza navona
in rome okay
so now what i mean by that is
okay i'll i will read i may even zoom
during that period so a little work
quote unquote listen to a podcast listen
i've listened many times to this podcast
and and uh and to others and so the
direction that i would like to see the
world
get to
is what i
think is
the kind of quality of life that people
would like which is time for each other
time for learning time for culture time
for leisure time for fun
time for creative work time for a care
economy not to have people in factories
and mine shafts
in
hard physical work that they don't want
to do
and
i think that that's
what economics should be about actually
is the escape not only from poverty but
from drudgery uh and uh and the chance
to have a more fulfilling life yeah and
why not maybe some listeners are
thinking to themselves yeah i mean i
absolutely support these kinds of
economic policies i support a global
wealth tax i support um you know opening
up trade i support you know uh doing the
things that are necessary to reverse the
damage that climate change has had on
poorer regions particularly in
sub-saharan africa etc all those things
i support but they feel sort of outside
of my uh immediate ability to to affect
change what would you say
the individual just the normal
individual who wakes up and gets a
coffee at starbucks and you know and a
burger at shake shack and then comes
home and watches you know hours and
hours of the office on is it on netflix
now i don't know i've never actually
watched the office i i hear it's a good
show though it's overrated what can an
individual do
in their mind in their heart
with their wallet
to
take part in the alleviation of global
poverty well look you know truly let's
just stay with the united states for one
moment
there are plenty of things we should be
doing
in this country right now
to help uh the one in seven households
that don't have enough to eat uh that
these so-called snap you know
supplementary nutrition uh program is
not funded adequately you need to help
for poor people with child care and so
on this is not an america first argument
to be sure but the reason i'm saying it
is that
president biden's proposing a lot of
things and the republicans right now
to a person are saying no
50 to nothing we have mitch mcconnell
saying literally saying not
kind of hiding
he says i'm working overtime
to make sure this administration fails
yep that is what we call normal politics
i would
send this guy packing that makes a
statement like this at that moment
because as americans we don't want
the
minority leader of the senate working
overtime to make sure that the
administration fails because that makes
sure that america fails jeffrey sachs it
is time for what we like to call the
lightning round here it's very simple
here we just ask you uh a few kind of
big existential questions
and then you have to answer them
immediately without thinking what was
the happiest day of your life i i
already told you it's sitting and having
coffee in the piazza nevona with my wife
sonia so right that's it there you go
tell us about your most enlightening
spiritual experience that's a little bit
different yeah it's probably sitting
on a hillside in ethiopia
in a completely impoverished
desperately poor place
i was talking about all the nice things
that could happen
and an old man
stood up hunched over
in uh white linens
and came up to uh
came up to a it was a kind of a bull
horn through a car battery as a
microphone on the hill and said
you're you're the first person that has
ever come from the outside to our
village uh to uh help us
and
it was a
incredibly moving moment uh
just
it was one of those moments where you
just felt a human connection that was so
incredible and so
special and unexpected uh it it has uh
really lasted with me it still makes me
tingle what's one thing uh that you
would change about yourself if you could
can i say more time in piazza in a
moment
what happens to us after we die well i i
i hope that something that we have
done will continue to uh
to be good for our children our families
our neighbors and the world uh that
that's what happens to us is that we
have
been part of uh of the human story uh
and uh hope hopefully
something uh something lasts i i know
that it does from
uh
people who are uh and for my parents and
uh grandparents and so on so that's what
i hope that i can leave if you had to be
either bill gates or jeff bezos
which one would you be
well definitely jeff bezos because i
could give away even more money than
bill gates
even even roughly twice as much uh jeff
bezos has a yacht that has its own yacht
and it has its own coffee shop on a
piazza then i'm going
what is one skill you wish you had i you
know i worked with bono a little while i
mean actually for more than a little
while and i kept asking if i couldn't be
the fifth member of the band
and he plainly detected that i lacked
the requisite skills so that is
happening you can play tambourines i
want to be the tambourine player in the
back
suggested that yeah
uh
if you could have lunch with any author
past or present who would it be and why
i think aristotle
questions you know little known fact
about aristotle never picked up the
check
wow
never would i i'd be well i'd be willing
what an [ __ ] check if i could have a
good luck what is one book that has
changed your life the book that i read
this year
that i found
completely overpowering
is by w.e.b du bois black reconstruction
which i think is probably the greatest
single book of american history wow uh
he was uh
a genius
but more than being a genius he was a a
an african-american who was fighting the
entire academic
establishment which was deeply racist at
the time
and he threw his genius in this
massive uh
magnum opus
i
absolutely upended all of amer american
understanding uh
about uh the role of african americans
in in u.s society and then finally what
is your life's big question
what makes for a good and decent
society
well jeffrey sachs thank you so much for
joining us uh the newest book is the
ages of globalization but you are the
author of so many other books that we
have talked about including of course
the end of poverty
thank you for enlightening us this has
been a wonderful conversation jeffy
wefee thank you for being here thank you
so much so great to be with you guys
really appreciate it
i like that jeff uh sax guy so many
great ideas you know what i like about
him like he was telling that last story
and i think it's true like he's he
he's not like in an economist who sits
you know behind an ivory tower and like
you know punches numbers into a
calculator which i assume is what an
economist does i don't know that's what
i always
that's all they do this guy like you
know he he goes all over the world like
he has met the people that he writes
about he knows their families he knows
their issues and their problems like
this isn't obviously as you can tell
this is an emotional thing for him so
he's walked the walk you know and um
he doesn't just have words you know he
has deeds to back it up yeah absolutely
his whole goal
being this idea that that really blew my
mind like economic bliss yeah um
which is all
like hanging out like um
like the great apes you know with a
stick picking bugs off of each other or
hanging out in a in a coffee shop in a
piazza what i like is that this idea
that oh what do people need
uh so that they have economic you know
dignity and it's like well you could
talk about things like well they need a
shelter and they need to be able to like
have health these are obvious things but
like what does it mean to truly no
longer be mired in abject poverty the
ability to pursue economic bliss which
can be any it could be like seeing your
kids go to a school like that could be
economic bliss you know or having coffee
in it in the piazza yeah what's your
economic bliss hit me number one it's
like
not
stressing
about money
which i get is a is an absolute
privilege right it's a total privilege
like i don't i don't want to be like
stupid rich
i mean i what i'm trying to say is my
yacht doesn't need its own yacht i can
just be happy with a yacht
yeah maybe a dinghy
i think
the this sort of
having
felt what it's like to lose sleep
because you don't know will i be able to
pay this bill or what happens that like
my economic bliss is just
not having that
yeah i i'll make a bold statement i'm in
my economic bliss so
my job then is to try and get other
people to theirs you know i'm not trying
to say i'm some kind of saint or
something like that but
you know i'm doing fine i'm doing i've
got residuals uh i've got savings um i
don't want to pass it on to my son i
know this is kind of a revolutionary
concept i want him does walt know this
is this the first time he's heard this
he's like wait yeah what don't please
don't let him listen to this podcast
okay if if anyone is with him um
but
uh you know i want to give away my money
and and i want that money to go towards
as efficiently as possible
uh allowing for other people's economic
bliss and
through the study that i have done over
the decades that is what my wife and i
work on which is girls education there
is no better way to spark an economy and
raise a standard of living than by
educating women and girls because they
spread what they learn and they um and
they uplift economies uh the studies
that have been done around it i'm not
gonna list it right now you just google
it um
but uh that's my economic bliss
all right well i'm not gonna i mean you
you just made me feel like [ __ ] now i
win so i win sorry but uh thank you jeff
sacks dr jeffy wefee for diving deep
with the metaphysical milkshake team
let's hear from our what about you dear
listeners i mean i'm surely you have
your ideas of what economic bliss will
be whether it's you know being able to
sleep without worry or giving your vast
fortune
to girls around the world like my
co-host is is going to
or do you think that that's a realistic
goal do you have do you debate that idea
that we're ever going to have a planet
where everyone is living in economic
bliss
i don't know would love to hear from you
so as you all know not only do we love
it when our fans rate and review us on
apple podcast because it makes us feel
good we have very fragile egos rain
especially
so needy but
as we've promised many times on this
show if you read and review us if you
ask a good enough question
uh you'll get to meet us you get to come
on the show and that is exactly what has
happened one of our big fans
kayla from virginia is here joining us
on the pod hi kayla
hi guys
god damn it it's kyla this says kayla i
get kayla a lot i also respond to kyle
do you have you have a ques a life's big
question my big question
is how can humans become closer to each
other in this era of great divide
intention i feel like
i've been pondering this a lot because
of covid
and just the type of person i am i look
for life lessons and everything i
became really sick when i was in eighth
grade with
numerous health conditions and what
really helped me
kind of be able to mentally cope with
all that is to just think about what
life lessons the universe or whatever
was trying to teach me and so one of the
ways i've been trying to get through
covid and political divide and just the
craziness that's going on in our world
is to try and evaluate what am i being
taught and what are humans being taught
time and time again like what oprah says
about how the universe whispers to you
with life lessons
so yeah that's my big question my friend
oprah does say that that's true my
neighbor oprah has said that before
look rayne loves this question you know
i love this question and so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to throw to
reza because we have heard me on this
podcast time and time again talk about
finding commonality
increasing compassion
seeking ways to heal
reza i'm not so sure is on the same page
but i'm making a president if you were
going to answer this
this is not going to answer how can we
become closer to each other in this time
of great tension disunity and divide
what would you what would you say
i i don't look kyla she's a freshman
she's just starting her her life as an
adult she's in college she's she's
brightly bushy tails she wants to hear
some hope the last thing she wants for
me to like destroy her
hope and humanity it's okay i can handle
it here this is what we're gonna do i'm
gonna give you i'm gonna give you the
bad version of this and then rain will
give you the good version of it and then
you'll feel much better about yourself
sounds good number one look i'm all
about
finding
each other's common humanity i mean it's
kind of what i've dedicated my life to
right i
my entire life has been dedicated to
using stories and storytelling in order
to break through the walls um that
separate us into these false categories
of different races or different
religions or nationalities or
ethnicities
and to and to really reach us where we
actually are you know as as human beings
and and to get to those things that we
hold in common
but that's different to me
than
the
refrain of oh this country is so
politically divided how do we reach
across the aisle and to the other side
and bring them uh to us and my answer is
[ __ ] the other side
and i mean that you know i'm being i'm
tongue-in-cheek about it obviously but
i just think that
sometimes
that divide is good and necessary
there should be a moral
divide right
i mean i i you know i'm a moralist like
i believe that there are
certain
um
you know moral absolutes
that are
non-negotiable
one of those moral
absolutes for me at least
is
the dignity of all human beings
and if you are on the other side
and you are making arguments
about how
people of a certain color or people of a
certain religion or of a certain you
know sexual orientation
um should not have should not have
access to the same you know human
dignities as other people [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i am not gonna spend
half a second of effort
reaching out to you go [ __ ] yourself as
far as i'm concerned
right now i get that there's a whole
mealy middle
of people who
are being inundated with messages from
both sides really really middle melee
was i don't know it just there's
something about the alliteration that i
enjoyed i don't know why i said okay but
i get that there's like this mass in the
middle that is constantly buffeted by
both sides and and often you know
responds with with fear and and and
um and anger and and and can be swayed
right and i think that that's what i'm
talking about when i say you know it is
important to try to reach their common
humanity
but when i look at
the quote-unquote other side of the
aisle
what i see are people who
do not deserve
to be reached out to
who who i have no interest in trying to
convince
them about my humanity
you know i'm done doing that
so
i don't decry the political divide in
this country good good i'm very happy
about the divide in this country and i
am very confident about where i stand in
this divide
now i will let reign give you the the
loving and huggy version of this answer
which i like i wish i was rain
i could i could certainly give the
lovey-huggy version of that but i think
i think that way of looking at it is
misguided because what it is is it's
looking at the divide in the country
through a partisan lens so it's
and this is kind of where why i think
partisanship itself partisan politics
the two-party system especially although
even if you had a six-party system it
would probably break down into two
essential factions
it's it's so corrupt because
it
um it polarizes people more and more and
it encourages power grabbing and we have
a
system of governance that's based
completely on power and control
and some some who have been disempowered
certainly need more power that's that's
important but if power is the end goal
then
you know you're just going to end up
like you are in nicaragua right now
where the leftist regime is locking up
all the reporters i lived there as a
child for three years and we were there
uh right uh before and during the
revolution of the sandinistas you'll
learn about this in your sociology class
perhaps and the the pendulum just swings
around because there is a constant grab
for power
so i would set sidestep and say
what we need to do is set power aside
and
forget partisan politics you know
whether or not to like work with mitch
mcconnell on new legislation about you
know gay rights and blah blah blah this
and the border here and police defunding
this or whatever like no i'm not even
going to talk about that because that
doesn't really interest me but
we have to as a species step away from
this constant partisan bickering which
is deadlocked our government and is and
here's why it's not huggy
is an
airy fairy and and and warm and fuzzy
because it's not working it's not going
to work and it's going to work less and
less and less as we go forward so
by all means reza applaud the the great
partisan divide in this country but
you're going to find more and more
things breaking down and not working if
we cannot work together so
that set aside it's about i believe
uh building coalitions of people um no
matter what their belief systems where
there is a commonality of mutual love
and respect for one another and you and
each other's humanity and trying to
essentially
i don't know sidestep politics create a
new system of politics a new system of
kind of being in the world
that
is not so engaged in this
kind of corrupt power struggle which
involves the raising of hundreds of
millions of dollars and
legislators and
prognosticators and marketers
and public relations managers and
whatnot because that system is just
broken so if you're engaging in that
system you're engaging in a completely
broken way of looking at things i think
oftentimes right now
in america because things are so
politicized
just through the media and everything i
think we forget that
you know there are some people on
extreme sides of the spectrum who are
saying that if you take the vaccine you
know you'll turn into a crocodile and
are just promoting like propaganda so
there is that side of it
but i think that we have a lot more
moral common ground
than we initially
you know would assume just from looking
at like msnbc versus fox news or the
other new one that's even worse than fox
news now
but i think
i think that's very true that we just
need to
work together towards a goal and just
realize that we're going to have to
do this so that we can
get stuff together and fix things for
our future generations because
i'm 18 and i already know i'm gonna have
to try and fix this mess the mess we
created right sorry about that by the
way
yeah so sorry i apologize i think that
we need your optimism and can do spirit
uh because as soon as you're jaded and
cynical it gets very very difficult to
get things done so i applaud your big
heart and the
the place in that heart where this
question comes from so kyla thank you so
much for being on the show thank you
thank you so much for having me i love
the show
you can find us at reza aslan
at rain wilson of course you can find us
on twitter at metamilkpodcast or on
instagram at metaphysical milkshake let
us know your life questions who knows we
just might explore them on a future
episode please remember to follow rate
and review uh metaphysical milkshake on
apple podcasts and wherever else you
listen to your podcasts yep and you can
also subscribe of course to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
and see that rain has shaved his beard
and he looks weird it looks weird
without a beard man i feel like a big
weird like giant baby alien face would
you like to see rayne wilson as a giant
baby well then you're gonna have to
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube page easy that's right thanks
for listening tell your friends thanks
for helping us solve global poverty good
night everybody see you next week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold and audio mixed by justin
kyle original music by jeff tang
we reach 100 000 subscribers i will do
an episode while wearing a diaper you
heard that here folks make this happen
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you